هذه الكلمات اشبه بالبشرى الامريكيين
اتفاق بين الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين لكنه
من حيث المبدا يقول رئيس مجلس النواب كيفن
مقاضي فما طبيعته هذا الاتفاق
وفقا للمعلومات سيعلق الالتزام بسقف الدين
البالغ حاليا واحدا وثلاثين تريليونا و400
مليار دولار حتى بدايه عام
2025 امر سيتيح للحكومه سداد التزاماتها
وفي المقابل سيتم الابقاء على الحد الاقصى
للانفاق التقديري غير الدفاعي عند مستويات
العام الحالي في عام 2024
وزيادته بواحد بالمئه فقط في 2025
ستخصص الحكومه الامريكيه
936 مليار دولار للانفاق التقديري غير
الدفاعي في العام الحالي وهي اموال يتم
توجيهها الى الاسكان والتعليم والصلاه على
الطرق
من المتوقع ان يرفع الاتفاق الانفاق
الدفاعي الى نحو 885 مليار دولار اي بواقع
11% عن 800 مليار دولار المخصصه في
الميزانيه الحاليه
من المتوقع ايضا استعاده الاموال غير
المستخدمه التي سبقت تخصيصها للتخفيف من
تداعيات كورونا بما في ذلك التمويل الذي
تم تخصيصه لابحاث اللقاحات والاغافه حيث
تشير التقديرات الى ان المبالغ غير
المستخدمه تتراوح بين خمسين وسبعين مليار
دولار
سيفرض الاتفاق متطلبات عمل جديده على ذوي
الدخل المنخفض الذين يتلقون مساعدات
غذائيه بموجب برنامج سناب حيث سيتم
تطبيقها على المستفيدين حتى سن اربعه
وخمسين عاما وليس حتى 56 عاما كما اقترح
الجمهوري
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات